Speaker 1: . It is Friday and it's time for
the mailbag.
You can email info at David Pakman dot com
if you have something to say.
Sometimes we'll look at tweet, sometimes we'll
look at YouTube.
Comments could be from anywhere.
Let's get right into it.
First one today indeed does come to us from
YouTube.
It's from John.
John says, David.
Speaker 2: Why.
Speaker 1: Won't you talk about Hunter Biden's
laptop?
You must support Russia, Ukraine and China.
David, you are our shame.
Well, another unintelligible screed, very
common to YouTube.
We've talked about Hunter Biden's laptop as
a media story, probably a handful of times.
And of course, I must support Russia and Ukraine
and China.
Those are all players on different sides of
the game, different perspectives.
I'm starting to think that John may not be
fully versed in geopolitics based on this
message.
Michael wrote in about the Fox News mass shooting
response and says, Hey, David, curious as
to how Fox News and other right wing types
could possibly believe that prayer and church
is the answer when the U.S. is 30th worldwide
in percentage of atheists.
And I know you know where we rank in the world
for mass shootings.
I am sick of these people not having any responsibility
for the nonsense they spew out on a daily
basis.
It makes me want to quit paying attention
to anything political.
Hope is gone.
Yeah.
With all of these things, there's always some
absurdity where all signs point to guns as
at least a major factor that has to be dealt
with.
We don't have enough religion.
Well, we have way more religion than most
countries, and we also have way more shootings.
So if you want to look at that correlation,
it doesn't bode particularly well for God.
Maybe God just isn't a factor in this one
way or the other.
And it's time to actually look at guns.
I don't know, just an idea, but Mike from
Atlanta accurately pointing that out.
Kristof wrote in and said, Can we talk about
the irony that the people who for the past
two years were crying about the psychological
effect that masks would have on?
Children at schools now want children to wear
ballistic blankets in case of a shooting and
watch their teacher shoot someone in front
of them.
Yet it's actually multilayered.
And I tweeted about some of these things.
On the one hand, the COVID masks were irreparably,
psychologically traumatizing to the kids.
But wearing a bulletproof backpack, backpack,
a ballistic blanket and having their teachers
be armed is supposed to not have a detrimental
psychological impact.
That obviously makes no sense.
But there's also the hypocrisy when it comes
to the teachers.
The these are the very teachers that the right
wing has spent the last two years saying these
are groomers.
These are people perpetuating the psychological
abuse by enforcing mask rules.
They're indoctrinated.
They are jokesters.
They are critical race theory, teaching, indoctrinate
ers who can't be trusted.
Let's give them the ultimate responsibility
of being armed in school so that they can
take out mass shooters.
Wait, you've just said they're not even capable
of choosing the books your kids should learn
from.
And now you want to give them guns.
It's completely absurd.
And Kristof accurately points it out.
Anthony wrote in about the Texas school shooting
and says, I thought your piece on the Texas
school shooting was quite good.
With one exception, you didn't have time to
question how hardening the schools with weapons
is going to take care of the movie theaters
and grocery stores and churches and all the
other places.
Crazy people decide to go and shoot people
for fun.
How would the right wing gun toting, bible
beating right to life or solve that otherwise?
Excellent work.
David That's Anthony from SAG Harbor.
Yeah, this is a point that I made during a
livestream.
But Anthony's right.
I missed this during during our podcast segment,
which is even if you did all the stuff they
want to do it schools and even if it worked,
which of course it's like they don't want
to deal with the gun part, but imagine you
did it all.
You can't do it at a ton of these other establishments
that have had shootings.
You can't do it at the grocery stores for
practical purposes.
You can't do it at the movie theaters.
It's now it's fair to say we need different
solutions to different problems.
That's absolutely fine.
But again, at some point you've got to deal
with the guns.
You're not going to have solutions to all
these things without ever dealing with the
guns, which is exactly what they want to do.
Samuel wrote in about Marcus Flowers.
Okay, this is an important email.
Samuel says, David, Sir, I applaud you for
recommending campaign involvement to your
audience, but I really caution against sending
sending excess time and donations to Marcus
Flowers campaign.
I worry too many progressives will make the
same mistake they made with the Amy McGrath
campaign in 2020 out of a passion to oust
Mitch McConnell, only to see her lose big
time.
Instead, I would recommend efforts going towards
Flippable races.
Tim Ryan in Ohio, Beasley in North Carolina,
Fetterman in Pennsylvania and defending vulnerable
incumbents, Spanberger in Virginia and Slotkin
in Michigan.
The truth?
There simply aren't enough Democratic voters
to oust GREENE Something something I obviously
want to see happen someday in that district.
And the primary numbers from Wednesday reflect
that.
In my judgment, it's better to keep green
and the minority then naively assume we can
remove her at this time.
This is a completely fair point.
I'm never going to say.
Ignore this race.
Okay.
But it is absolutely true that the numbers
in Marjorie Taylor GREENE district make it
hard to believe that in such a red district,
the non-incumbent Democratic nominee, Flowers,
is going to be able to win.
Now, I'm not saying ignore the race, but we
do have limited resources.
And I think Samuel makes an important point
here about understanding how to best use those
admittedly limited resources.
Keep it in mind.
Okay.
Hannah wrote in and says, Recession soon.
Hi, David.
I'm hearing more news stories that say the
U.S. is barreling toward recession right now
and that this recession will start within
the next year.
Do you agree?
Why or why not?
Thank you, Hanna.
Here's the difficulty of this question.
We may already be in a recession.
We may be getting out of it right now.
We you know, everybody defines it differently.
Understand that for a decade, many have been
saying a recession is imminent.
Around 2015, there were lots of people saying
a recession is imminent.
Imagine if you had listened to them in 2015
and said, I believe the recession is imminent.
I'm getting out of the stock market.
You would have missed one of the greatest
run ups in the stock market in decades.
So my view is I don't know if a recession
is coming.
I can't control whether a recession is coming.
At some point there will be another recession.
What do I know?
Well, I know my principles.
I know that my principle is asset allocation
and my principle is low cost index funds without
trying to time the market.
And my principle is when the market goes down,
those same index fund purchases get me more
shares at a lower price because I can't time
it.
I don't know whether a recession is coming.
And so I think a lot of times the right question
to ask is if a recession were coming, what
would I do or what would I do differently?
For most people, the answer is, well, actually
nothing.
I wouldn't do anything differently.
So I don't have the answer about a recession.
But what I do have is a plan.
That is the plan whether or not we are in
a recession.
I hope that makes sense.
Neil's road in with an idea for when we get
to 1.5 million YouTube subscribers and Neil
says, Hi David on achieving 1.5 million subscribers
May I suggest you receive a colonoscopy on
air?
So the joke here is recently someone wrote
in and said, David, you should do a colonoscopy
when you get to 1.5 million subscribers.
And the wording was funny because typically
it's the doctors doing the get the colonoscopy
and it's the patients receiving.
So I was like, are you saying that I should
receive one or that I should perform one?
Neil's is clarifying that and saying I should
receive the colonoscopy when I get to 1.5
million subscribers.
Well, that's something we will look into.
Okay.
Lucas has a different idea.
Lucas.
Hello, David.
Love your show.
I've been watching the last two years now,
watching your show, reading suggestions for
what to do for 1.5 million on YouTube.
I think you should eat a Carolina reaper.
It is the world's hottest pepper, and I feel
like it would gather a lot of attention to
your channel.
You should also set a date for when you want
to hit it in order to eat the pepper.
I'm just going to pass on that.
I am not interested in hot peppers.
I mean, listen, I love a good jalapeno.
I'll use Fresno chilies in cooking dried Thai
chilies Serrano for a beautiful coconut cod
chowder that I like to make you chop up a
Serrano pepper.
It's beautiful, smoky heat.
But I don't like stunts like this.
I don't like eating contests.
And I have no this is a no.
This is a hard no.
I would sooner bleacher my hair or shave my
head then than do this.
Stacy wrote in, Does a fetus have a right
to get child support?
Hi.
If life begins at conception, shouldn't child
support start at conception?
Yours, Stacey.
I've brought this up many times before.
The issue about personhood at conception raises
really important questions.
If a fetus is a citizen, if a citizen if a
fetus is a person at conception, then it is
a citizen.
Right?
I mean, it should be able to be made a citizen.
And even if it's the fetus of an undocumented
immigrant, they should be able to get citizenship
after conception, because if it's a person,
people get citizenship.
If it is a person at conception, then presumably
it would be entitled to child support as well.
I mean, listen, good luck actually having
rational conversations about these things
with the anti-choice movement.
But of course, Stacey brings up a good point,
which is it's less about when do we say life
has started?
Forms of life exist in so many places and
in so many ways.
And a fetus is less about whether it qualifies
as, quote, life.
But what is a person and what are the rights
that come with personhood?
Because the anti-choice movement wanted to
talk a lot about specific rights that they
believe a fetus should have, but not about
many of the others that people, persons also
get.
And it's an age old hypocrisy.
As long as Roe v Wade has been around, all
of these arguments have been around.
And sadly, they very often become philosophical
black holes and you don't get anywhere with
them.
But an important question.
Info at David Pakman dot com.
If you have questions, comments, suggestions
that you would like featured in the weekly
mailbag, make sure that you are signed up
at join Packman dot com and get a membership,
get the bonus show and get the commercial
free audio and video feeds of the show every
day, 6 hours before they are published to
everybody.
Join Comic-Con is the place to sign up.